5 minutes to think to yourself on why that is an incredibly stupid
thing you just said in the chat. There's a button where I don't
have to live with Asmongold people. Oh, boom boom boom boom boom.
Can I hit it 100 times? Boom boom boom boom boom boom boom. Not
only are you guys psychotic, you're gay
>> Let's see what else we got here. We're going to go on
to this Asmongold segment
This was getting thrown about a lot recently, okay? Guys,
here is the hypothetical for the red button, blue button segment,
okay?
Everyone on Earth takes a private vote by pressing a red or blue
button. Now, that means every single person takes a private vote.
That means you can't be coached on the vote. It's just like a
blue button goes out in front of them and they press a button,
okay? Now, that's everyone on Earth. There are no other qualifications
there. Everyone on Earth. Okay. If more than 50% press of people
press the blue button, everyone survives. If less than 50% of
the people press the blue button, only people who press the red
button survive. Which button would you press? Be honest.
Now, there is like a mathematical game theoretical answer to
this. It's the red button. It's just the prisoner's dilemma,
uh like a a scaled-up version of the prisoner's
I would hope everybody can understand that just because that's
the optimal pick for you specifically,
that you should be able to infer or think about for a millisecond
how this would affect other people, how other people would would
talk about this. Blue button is a fact. You are able with no
second order thought. Now, let me ask.
Let me ask, okay?
If it were real, then it would be the red button. I don't think
so.
Does anybody have any second order thoughts on this? Anything.
Hey, if if every single person on Earth presses that button,
what does that mean?
It's not saying you're getting like a bunch of coaching on this.
What if it's just like mentally you you get asked like which
one would you
Assuming children get no help, which is the assumption, Chappie,
if you're not a
Okay? Which is the assumption. Children get no help, the infirm
get no help, the blind get no help, right? There are a bunch
of people here who don't get any help. So, it requires you doing
a little bit of thinking beyond yourself, which I understand
is very difficult for most human beings, right? Before you sell
the audience, get a
Oh, I don't care about what people here
to be honest with you. I I I straight-up It's fine. Looks like
it's going to be close to 50/50. I straight-up don't care what
the people here think. I'm going to educate you. What you think
doesn't matter. What you know about 10 minutes from now when
you realize you should be clicking the blue button, that's what
matters, okay? There's no way to guarantee 100% red. Use your
brains, press blue. It's kind of like that, right? It would be
red IRL, Twitter polls, and what you think is optimal doesn't
matter either. I Okay.
I'm going to press blue, think about this other people, and if
a bunch of other people press red, I'm assuming most of the people
I care about are pressing blue, you know? I understand that basically
everybody here is like going to be
Oh man, how how should I put this? Like very self-interested.
They can't think about other people. And I'm fine with that.
If the human If the human race can't think about other people
to that extent, I'm okay with that. How do we get rid of the
red button pushers though? I don't know. I don't know, man.
Difficult to say. Uh hold on. Hold on.
My initial thoughts are red, but easily swayed blue with more
thought. Yeah, I think a lot of people they just see red right
away. But, it's like okay.
That's the whole point though. It's supposed to weigh It's essentially
supposed to test you for like how selfish your own reasoning
is.
That's what it's supposed to be supposed to do, right? Can you
even Can you even like think about other people existing?
Most Most people can't. Most people have no concept of that.
And maybe that's like But, to me that's basically proof that
haha
human race just ceases to exist pretty quickly here. We're not
going to make
I hope not, but hey. Seems to be the case. Right? And assuming
a bunch of people go like, well, assuming coordination, you should
just sign up for like the um Everybody should press the red button.
It's like, no. You can coordinate, you press the blue button.
I logic'd it.
I You logic'd it. Very cool.
Red is the correct answer. Red is just a game game theoretical
answer. That's what it is.
And I understand that the lowest risk option is red. That is
the game theoretical answer. The particularly funny thing to
me The The best response I saw to this was Lauren Chen saying
she picked red. >> paypig.
Very embarrassing for her, let me tell you. Uh Lauren Chen as
a mother is saying she's going to hit the red
You understand you can't coach your kids, right? You understand
that the button appears, you just have to press it. And even
if you could coach your kids, it's a private vote. You're not
going to be able to tell them in the moment what to do. How do
you know that they won't actually just go and
blow themselves up?
I would hope most parents could do this thinking. You'd think
parents should have the ability to do this, right? More than
anybody.
It's very disturbing to me when when a parent comes in and goes,
"No, it's obviously red, guys."
Maybe she wants a break. God, don't be selfish. Well, a lot of
embarrassing selfish people around, man.
Yeah, this is another thing. Yes, kids are just So, they'll do
the opposite. Yeah, if you Are you going to trust your kid not
to [__] around when the moment
Hey kids, press this button. Will you You tell them to press
the blue button with you or you I don't even know what you tell
them.
You'd press the blue button though, right? You press the blue
button and you advocate for them to press the blue button. And
if they [__] around and press red, then hopefully
everybody else presses blue. That's actually the exact reason
I'm picking red. Okay, well.
Good luck, evil Johnny Bravo.
Every single like empathetic person is
I I don't think I even really care to live in this society where
red gets 50%
to be honest with you. You get every single like empathetic concerned
person out of society. Human beings are already selfish enough,
man.
Very sad. Anyway, listen.
We need to go to the Asmongold segment. Asmongold makes a very
different argument for his choice, okay? But, the Asmongold segment
I just thought was funny. >> that you can almost mechanically,
all right? Asmongold had a segment on this. It's very funny to
me. There are two buttons that you can press, the red button
and a blue button.
If more than 50% of people press the blue button, everybody lives.
Everybody lives if if more than if more than half of everybody
presses the blue button. But, if less than 50% of people press
the blue button, only the red button pressers survive.
So, basically, if you press
All of the Chinese and Indians are going red though, no? I don't
even know why Why do we think that? What part of like Chinese
culture is individualistic?
Massive numbers of people in Asia mean that society is very competitive.
Okay. >> button, if it's under 50%, you die. And if it's
over 50%, you live. And if you press the red button, if it's
over 50%, you you live and it's under 50%, you also live. You
weren't supposed to show it. It's extremely biased now. I I don't
think that I Oh my god. I I'm just saying I can see where the
propensity of red voters are and I'm good on the other side,
man. I'm just I'm good I'm good without the red button. I'm good.
I'm good. Yeah, you know what? I'm I'm hitting blue cuz I pray
to God I never get stuck in a world where a huge majority people
would be viewers, okay? Holy sh I think this is what my viewers
would say. Let me just opt the [__] out of that immediately.
Oh my god. There's a button where I don't have to live with Asmongold
people. Oh, boom boom boom boom boom. Can I hit it 100 times?
Boom boom boom boom boom boom. Let's just Let's just keep gambling
and see what happens. Boom boom boom boom boom boom. I just don't
have to be around them. Awesome. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. I'll opt out every time. >> I'm going to give you
guys my >> Concentrated essence of Asmongold viewer. No,
thanks, man.
I'm going to give you my answer to this this moral conundrum,
okay? This is expected. It is.
I think and this is going to shock a lot of people, I'd press
the blue button. He goes blue.
>> you know why?
It's because we Because you're a reactionary, incredibly reactive,
incredibly emotional, and this is going to tie into something
you made a video about yesterday. Also, I pre-watched. >> to
live in a society.
We did. We used to live in a society. Oh my god. >> to
And you're not going to let the third worldists who want to steal
from each other and just rule society cuz that's the thing you
were thinking about yesterday and that's what's informed all
of your decision-making today. >> to live in a world.
You see, remember what I was saying about third worldism?
One of the main core tenets of that is the idea of the self over
the over the community over the society.
This is so not true, by the way. Like the third worldists in
a lot of cases are about collectivism far more.
It's kind of crazy. >> And I think that in a first world
Western culture, the true like what button would someone like
uh Socrates press? What button would uh you know, Plato press?
What button would Aristotle press? What button would Caesar press?
And I think that they That's what Asmongold thought, right? Caesar,
Roman law, Plato, Aristotle, Greek philosophy.
Dude, it's like the same thing from yesterday.
Christian morality,
Greek philosophy, Roman law. OH MY GOD.
>> CAESAR Caesar's 100% pressing red. I think Caesar's
pressing red, yeah. Mostly out of like narcissism or whatever.
Yeah, he's definitely not pressing blue. >> the blue button.
They would. And red No, I I disagree.
Maybe you get
Aristotle voting blue. Caesar definitely doesn't vote blue. I
do. I disagree. If red wins the world collapses and the majority
will die of starvation.
Well, here's the issue that I have. That's also true by the way.
If you lose cuz you I assume neither one is going like 70/30.
Unless you can get it to like 95/5,
you snap out of existence like 20, 30, 40% of the population,
you're totally
Which is another reason you should be voting blue if you have
any second order thinking skills at all, but most people don't.
Many people lack these. of right is that I don't want to live
in a world where everybody does that. Like I think this this
is a bad world to live in, especially when it's just for a
like a completely arbitrary reason. So, my outlook on it is that
as Gemini which button Socrates would press.
Okay, [laughter] fine.
I I'll do that. No, no, no, we'll we'll we'll do that. We're
going to now use AI to figure out what the greatest philosophers
of all time thought about the red button versus blue button question,
guys. This is Listen, maybe this is not a bad idea for a segment
to do like hypotheticals like this using AI. Not that it really
means much, but you know, maybe not the worst use of AI. Where
is Hold on, this was the this was the chat
on the poll here.
So, 28/14 was the poll. Jesus. All right, well, you know, I I
definitely leaned into that poll a lot. I should have just asked
beforehand before basically telling people what they should think,
but >> Where are the All right, let's see cuz I think he'd
press the blue button. I do. I think he I I think every I think
See, I
All right, all right, all right, all right, all right, all right,
next, next.
Who's the next one? So, Socrates would vote red. >> we
we got to go even farther than this. We got to go even farther
than this.
Who's the next one? >> Which button?
>> Got to be Aristotle for the next one,
I don't know who this is.
Nietzsche, Nietzsche.
>> Nietzsche is a [__] name. Nietzsche, Nietzsche.
>> How do you How do you How do you type his name? Like
I can't I can't spell How do you How do you spell his name? Okay.
I mean, dude, like the the the the name's complicated, all right?
It's not even my fault.
He's got it. He's got it now. Nietzsche Nietzsche got to be red
button, right?
Am I crazy? I feel like Nietzsche's got to be red button cuz
he wrote about the whole slave morality thing. He basically argues
that you're like a like this is a slave morality question, right?
Voting blue button? Nietzsche's got to go red. >> All right,
next. I just thought it was crazy that he's so transparently
like motivated by the um by like the third worldism thing, the
thing that's been like Yeah, he's just like taking this philosophy
he's come up with the past like or come to the past I don't know
month or so, he's going to apply it directly to the situation
immediately. >> He'd press the blue button, too, by the
way. He would. Why? What? No.
Well, Socrates Well, Socrates chose the common good. Nietzsche
would view the blue button as a trap of slave morality. LET'S
GO!
VERY EASY. Very easy. Very easy. >> Wait, really? The blue
button the price of the of
Okay, okay, all right. So, we're we're half and half. Machiavelli?
Okay, we don't need to look that one up. We don't We don't need
to look at that one. That one's pretty easy. And okay, Michael
Uh let's see, who else?
Uh which button would Hitler press?
Hitler's got to be blue button, right?
Even though Hitler subscribed to like a lot of the Nietzschean
philosophy,
I think I feel like Hitler's got to be blue button, right? He
talks about collective all the time. Okay. Analyzing the prompt's
danger. Okay.
It [laughter] would also be the red
Uh looking at his ideology of social Darwinism, his extreme distrust
of internationalism. Oh, right, cuz it it takes into account
all the other nations, sure. Sure, sure, sure, sure, sure. I
didn't I wasn't thinking about that. I was thinking about his
collective with an out group, a very large out group. Got it.
That's my bad. >> Okay, it would be the red button. And
all right, there it is. What? Aristotle? Okay, I I bet Aristotle
would push the blue button. Okay,
what about Aristotle? Okay. All right, this is the last one.
All right. And actually, one more. Of course.
Aristotle blue button. You said Caesar. He's got to ask about
>> Right. Blue button again. All right, one
Marcus Ru I thought it was crazy that that he said blue button
in the first place. I just thought it was crazy to me. Because
it's obvious this entire chat's about red button. It's obvious
that's what everybody thought he was going to press. What about
Type it out for me, guys. Just type it out. Just I'm not even
going to try.
Just just type it out for me. Marcus Rubius? No, no, no, no,
no. Okay. Cuz cuz I I I already know I'm not even going to make
a fool out of myself.
He would also press the blue button. Maybe. I feel like intuition
would tell me red, but I know he has some things in stoicism
that don't really like the way people or like the way people
talk about stoicism now, modern day, there's some things they
leave out. Possibly blue. These are the architects
of Western civilization.
These
are the founders of our culture. You have been infected with
third
and you don't even know it.
WE WAS ROMANS, MAN. WE WAS ROMANS.
THIS IS SO SAD. It's so tremendously
That like you you you like even [laughter] Hitler?
Like I'm not counting Hitler, okay? Remember he lost the war?
Remember how that happened?
Can I do Trump? Okay, all right, all right, all right. You guys
I think it's going to I mean, come on. Come on. Is he just asking
AI for the rest of this? Refining survival strategy. Reuben Reuben
wanted me to watch this Stakuyiems video on this. So, I'm going
to pull this up real quick. We'll see how this goes. Maybe this
is short. Have you heard of the new blue and red thought experiment?
Um no. Tell me about it. So, everyone on Earth gets taken into
their own separate room and in it there's a desk with two buttons,
a blue one and a red one. There's a sign that says if 50% or
more of people push the blue button, Look, it's the guy who is
talking who's hypnotizing Charlie Kirk when he got shot in the
neck. everyone lives. But if 50% or more of people push the red
button, then everyone who pushed the blue button dies.
Which button are you pressing? How is this a thought experiment?
I obviously push blue. Well, it's a thought experiment because
I push red. What? Yeah, I don't want to die. Well, I don't want
to die, but I I don't want anyone else to die either, but it
seems like I'm the only person in this room who thinks that.
Oh my god, don't make this a moral thing. Sorry, how is this
not a moral thing? Okay, look, let me give a new thought experiment.
Oh, are you going to be a psychopath in this one, too? Okay,
everyone on Earth gets taken into their own separate room. In
the room there are two buttons, a blue one and a red one. There's
a sign that says if you press the red button, nothing happens.
And if you press the blue button, you die unless more than 50%
of people push the blue button. Now, which one are you pushing
now? Okay,
I I press red. Okay, well, guess what, Mr. Psychopath? Those
were the same thing. Okay, everyone should be pressing red. It's
not a moral thing. >> If you're getting fooled by the language
there, you are low IQ. >> I'm not going to jump in front
of a train just because you are, too. Stop jumping in front of
trains. Wait, like God, you guys think that everyone else is
such a terrible person when maybe it's the case that they're
just a little bit more rational than you. >> Wait, they're
not the same. They're not They're not the same thought experiment.
>> Yes, they are. You answered differently because you're
dumb. Yeah, but the sign says two different things. No, it's
the same thing. No, it's framing the same thing in two different
ways. Okay, what's the difference? The difference is that you
seem to know that most people are going to be confused by framing.
Yeah, I think that's what makes it a good thought experiment.
But you recognize that some people will be dumb, right? Well,
sure. And they're
Like like 6-year-olds. Like 6-year-olds would be very dumb.
6-year-olds might not even be able to >> going to die.
Well, because they're dumb. Yes, because they're dumb. Correct.
But are we killing people now because their IQ wasn't high enough
to parse the framing of the question when their life is on the
line?
No. So, we should vote blue to save the dumbasses and get ourselves
killed. Well, I think I have a more compassionate view of humans.
I think they're a lot dumber than you think they are. That's
the same thing. Just different framing. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. If this were limited to adults, would it change
your answer? Um if it were limited to only people who could understand
it, maybe.
Uh definitely the second one. If it was limited to only people
who could perfectly parse that language and all knew like what
the what the question was, maybe. That's not what the original
question is, though. And regardless, it's like yeah, just
It's just virtue signaling. It's just Asmongold virtue signaling,
which Asmongold oddly opted out of, I guess. I don't know, but
very sad. Very, very, very sad. Which is odd. I I see this I
see this like confusing a lot of people where it shouldn't. Like
it should absolutely never confuse you. You should never be confused
by this, but so many people seem to be confused by it. It's very
confusing to me. You'll never get You'd still never get 100%
compliance. You wouldn't. But then then if it's everybody understands,
if you do something where everybody understands it
and nobody's confused and everyone knows that there's like nobody
who doesn't understand who's voting in the wrong way, there's
no mistakes, you get to like triple check, if you do all of these
things, right?
Then obviously, you could get people at At with the second framing
you vote red.
This is interesting. You think it's vice
It is vice signaling.
Does your answer change if the world knew it was coming in a
month and got to coach their nations? No. Answer is blue even
more than. It's even more blue if you get a month to coach people
on what button they should press. It's even more blue.
Uh Evil Johnny Bravo, you're basically just arguing other people
are bad.
Other people are really bad and I'm not going to die for them.
But I don't know. Like I said,
if most people don't want to like be compassionate, save like
a good chunk of humanity who aren't going to
seems pretty easy to me that I'm like, "Okay, I'll opt out. It's
fine."
>> Oh, no. Asmongold would press the red button without
a moment's hesitation and he'd probably spend the next 20 minutes
on stream explaining why anyone who pressed blue is Yeah, that's
exactly why his entire audience voted red because they know
They know for sure. >> literally insane. His choice wouldn't
be based on malice, but on a blend of cynical Dude, who is the
[__] who told me yesterday who is like somebody in
my chat was like, "Um it's not at all like the prisoner's dilemma."
I It's like, "Wait, what? Am I s-
How? How could you think that?" And then it was it obviously
was just the prisoner's dilemma. cynical realism, common sense
logic, and a deep distrust of the collective intelligence of
the herd. Here's how he would break it down.
Wow. Asmongold often views world
It would be the most Asmongold thing in thing in the world. It
would be the most Asmongold thing in the world. If he got
tricked or if he got convinced to go back to the red button by
AI.
By AI describing what his thought process would be. That would
be insane. >> problems like game mechanics. He would immediately
see the red button as the strictly dominant strategy. Distrust
of the herd, the loophole logic, radical honestly. Yes, he would
mock the fake virtue of people
Doesn't the prisoner's dilemma end up with the possibility of
both people
There's a negative outcome to you both pressing the bad button.
Yeah, there's a there's like a negative outcome, but the idea
is because of the risk of the downside of them pressing the button
you not pressing the button,
you have to press the button. It's that is the basically the
deciding factor. >> will have pressed blue. And uh oh my
Red has no downside? That is only if you are a psychopath and
you think a bunch of your friends and family members dying is
not a downside.
You understand that, Red has no downside. No, you are a
You're a psychotic
You're arguing that people dying is not a downside. You're a
psychotic
Jesus, man. The high-minded duty and the self-righteous virtue
of logic. Yes, I would The sad thing is is you're not even embarrassed
about IT. YOU'RE A PROUD PSYCHOTIC which is the precise kind
of vice signaling idiot that I think needs to be
Like I think we need to start
these people's lives with hammers in a spiritual way.
>> I would push the blue button. I I would. I would. If
it was our society, I would push the blue button. Read the loophole.
Um what does it say? He loves pointing out when a situation is
solved just by reading the rules. Okay, everybody checks in.
Since everyone pressed red, everyone survives. So they conclude
the red superior humanitarian choice cuz it removes the risk
of death entirely so long as everyone smart enough to be selfish.
Well, they're not. They're they're not that cuz you know, like
think about how many women we have, right? For example. And I'm
sure I mean those are all going to be blue button pressers for
sure. And so like that's at least half of them pressing blue.
Oh, I didn't even think about that.
Not only are you guys psychotic you're gay psychotic
Cuz the gender split on the planet is going to get totally by
this. I forgot about that part. I forgot about that part. So
you're gay psychotic actually. And so like I I mean really you
don't really need to worry about this at all because like you
know, you got 50% of the population already pressing blue to
begin with. >> So yeah, I mean it's not a big deal at
Not dumb and press the blue button. It's overly empathetic.
Okay? That's just the way it is. That's how the personality traits
break down. Not my fault, not your fault.
Overly empathetic. You lost the plot with this scenario. But
why is it Okay, so so why is it that I've lost the plot, but
every architect of Western civilization agrees with me? Isn't
that like isn't that an interesting
um you know, coincidence?
It's a such a bad argument. I don't know. Sorry, it's like
If he knew the philosophies, if he knew why he was saying they
would agree with them, then maybe it's not dumb, but he literally
didn't know why they would say what they were going to say. And
so I'm sitting here like, how do you even You're literally just
return to tradition, man. Return to tradition.
It's It's It's It's It's It's I'm just saying like yeah, all
the arc- they're all there. Yeah.
If that was the point of it, Evil Johnny Bravo, if that was the
only point of it, then why wouldn't they just give the prisoner's
dilemma?
Like why even why even make it like a a different question?
And then it's just game theoretical. Why add the the people and
their lives into
Obviously, it's not just game theory. It's not just logical choice
cuz there's nothing interesting to that. There's nothing interesting
to like the game theory of it. Cuz it was a long time ago and
they despawned. That's what
Do Napoleon?
Honestly, I think it's just very telling that so many people
are like
almost like not just the reaction to not think about anyone else
at all, but then to double down and like have to defend it over
and over and over
It's maybe the thing I'm noticing most on Twitter. Like that
people are quite literally incapable of seeing all the points
for the other side and like just
No, no, no. I I'm still going to vote red. It's very goofy to
me. I I like I It's crazy. >> Okay. Um
Everyone goes red, they all live, right? Just keep coping. I
want you to think to yourself. You have 5 minutes to think to
yourself on why that is an incredibly stupid thing you just said
in the chat. He I don't know. I think I I think it's 50/50. I
think it could be it could could go either way. >> It could
go either way. Research it. Nobody dies if anyone presses 100%
of either button.
King Baldwin? Okay. All right. All right. Sorry. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. >> That's the last one I'm going to do because I
know that one's going to be on my side.
Issue is you're not going to get 100% of anything. You're going
to get like 95/5 at best on either one even with training even
with months of training. And so if you're going to go 95/5 one
way or the other, it's obvious which way that 95/5 should go.
That's the reason why. Okay, he did it Yeah, the red button.
I see. Okay. All right. Now we get to end it with one that I
know I'm going to I'm going to have on top. Do Jesus next. No,
no, no. All right. All right. What about King Baldwin? Okay.
All right. Last one. Last one. What about Jesus? Well, I mean
didn't didn't Jesus kind of do that? I feel like he kind of did
that, right? Yeah. And so George Washington? Okay. All right.
What about
Is this This is the guy from Kingdom of
Why do Why do Why is Asmongold asking you about the the king
from Kingdom of
What the
George Washington would push the blue
He would push the blue button.
This is the path of the Western man. You You have to understand
this. Like this is the way it is. Dude, Bruce Wayne, he's not
real. Bruce Wayne's not real. And so yeah, Joe Biden, he wouldn't
know what button it is. He probably push them both, right? And
yeah, no, I'm I'm telling you And we probably shouldn't kill
Joe Biden.
I don't want to kill Joe Biden. Sleepy Joe gets to live the rest
of his days, okay? You like I mean So I just want y'all to understand
this that like the This is an example of third worldism colonization
inside of first world countries that This is very funny to me.
Like unfortunately for Asmongold
here, he has to deal with the fact that you have the most uniquely
selfish culture in the world. America in the first world is the
is the disgusting spectacle to everybody else when they see how
self-centered and how selfish your average citizen is.
Every other country, every other first world country doesn't
have the same problems you do
cuz you are a uniquely selfish people.
Totally uniquely selfish.
Now that's Canada. Canada that has universal health care?
Canada that has universal health care? That has a ton of social
programs that takes care of the individual, the the tread upon,
the downtrodden? Yeah, okay. Okay. Yeah, you're right. Canada's
kind of like America where America's everything by your bootstraps
and Canada's all these social programs. Yeah, you're right. No,
you're not right. You're a complete [__] for saying
that. For even suggesting it. What are you doing?
What are you doing? PH2 car, come on, man.
Be better. >> That is so pervasive that we don't even realize
it. It It's It's so pervasive and so
And also the red So who would do the red
most people would click the blue button. So even in every single
circumstance, I I would I would survive, right? I would. And
so apes strong together and Western path of empathy? Well, no,
it it's just about having reliance on your fellow man. That's
it. And yeah, that's it. Do Kamala Harris?
She probably I mean you can't you can't make a decision like
that when you're under the influence of alcohol. You shouldn't
be able to do that. Bro, the third world population outnumber
us. They'd all press the red
I'm talking about it America. Like I mean obviously like if if
I had to Okay, I will say this. If I had to make this decision
for the whole world, I would have to press the red button. But
if I had to make the decision for America, I'd press the blue
button. Does that make sense?
Does that make sense? Like I mean I I would do that. What? Well,
let me explain why. It's because I realized that like our like
my ideology is not
most people are not western, you know, like western thinkers,
right? They they don't they don't do like that. So like but like
in America in in like a European country in a proper European
um you know, like you supposed to do that, right? That's the
way it's supposed to be. So he's red button got Well, I would
I would go back and forth, right? But like that's really but
it depends on who you're making a vote for, right? The original
No, the question was about the world. Everyone in the world.
Oh, I mean like everybody in the world like oh man. Like yeah,
I guess I guess you say everybody in the world I would do red.
But like if it was every There's no way.
I I'm going to count that as him getting convinced by the Asmongold
AI. I'm going to count that as him getting convinced by the Asmongold
AI, okay?
This idiot. Oh my goodness. >> Everybody in like America
I would do blue. You know, I guess that's it. And I do it the
opposite way. Could you imagine if the question was just like
a scythe from aliens?
And actually the people who press the blue button all get put
on one planet, the people who get press the red button all get
put on another planet.
Do you imagine how awesome the blue planet would be? That'd be
incredible. >> Yeah, you're right. About 50% of the world's
populace is going to press blue. Yeah, maybe you're right. I
mean there's a lot of women that might do it anyway, right? It's
it's impossible. And so the AI was right. Maybe. I mean I think
if it's the whole world, like I guess, but I would not make that
decision for like America. Does that make sense? So anyway, what
if the decision was only applied to Twitch streamers? Oh, Twitch
streamers are such massive
They would absolutely all press the blue button, okay? Oh, no.
No, if it was only Twitch streamers, I'm going red. If it's only
Twitch streamers, I'm going red knowing that we're going to get
100% red for the first time ever.
That is crazy that he just said that. Twitch streamers are the
biggest narcissists on planet Earth. There is no way you could
convince me to go anything but red button if it was just streamers,
man. Holy [__]
Absolutely 0% chance I'm going I'm going
and I'm not looking back. Ooh. But who made the button? How did
he get thrown so hard by who made the
What the Who made the button? He just has a full 5-second pause.
Bro, it's a thought exercise.
It doesn't matter. Say it doesn't matter, and then if it if you
need an answer, aliens.
Nobody knows. No nobody know nobody knows who made the button.
Nobody knows.
Uh yeah, nobody knows, guys. Like come on, like
Wow. Nobody knows. Nobody knows.